the las vegas raiders and at the time
they were the oakland raiders when they
did these deals antonio brown tyrell
williams lamarcus joyner trent brown
all now gone huge money invest now i
don't know how much antonio brown
ultimately got he had a series of
grievances after his
crazy 2019 season but my goodness
look chris and they're going to trade
trent brown to the patriots for nothing
it's a swap of future seventh round
picks and trent brown is redoing his
deal and i'm told that
you know trent brown was motivated to go
ahead and do this because the raiders
could have squatted on him for a while
waited until after the draft and his
potential alternatives could have dried
up so the patriots wanted to bring him
back
he does a deal now that allows him to be
a free agent next year
it's a win-win out of a bad situation
but
the worst part of it is the raiders
paying that kind of money that was one
of those
right out of the gates 2019 huge free
agency deals
moved him from left tackle to right
tackle and it's been
a disaster and the free agency for the
raiders the big money free agency has
been
a disaster and this traces back to the
idea that the guy who's running the show
doesn't have to worry about getting
fired chris i talked about this last
night on pftpm
yeah when your boss is not going to fire
you you can be a mad scientist you can
take all sorts of crazy chances there's
no accountability like there would be
for other coaches
slash de facto general managers so oh
yeah hey sorry mark we tried we're
trying to make a better team here you
know we don't know how these guys are
going to be until they show up that's
what the market required us to pay
we did what we had to do and now we're
going to move on to the next guy that's
how football works mark
uh sorry let's keep going no i mean
listen
i i think there's some truth there that
certainly i i know again
i don't think john gruden's trying to go
renegade on anything i think he is
trying to build something but yeah
obviously they've
they've made mistakes there's there's no
doubt about that you know lamarcus
joyner was underwhelming since he came
from the rans of course trent brown he
barely played
you know there's that you know there's
been the the the you know
the the misuse of draft picks hey clel
and colin farrell at number four
a few years ago it's it's a horrible
pick it's horrible
you know the the arnett kid uh
in the first round last year damon
arnett coming out of nowhere
you know again has talent but i don't
think he was a
what it was he the 19th pick of the
draft something like that
so they've taken some risk on a few
players and
it hasn't worked out and when you do
that and this is where
hey the politics of drafting and things
like that go in
then now people look at you extra hard
and go well what the hell were you
thinking
what were you doing so uh yeah it
doesn't look great for them right now
it's a big offseason i think that's why
they're cutting some of the fat here on
the offensive line because
they're starting to go all right wait we
got some weapons we got a running back
our quarterback's good
all right we got john gruden he's gonna
he can figure out how to protect and do
some of these things he's an offensive
genius without all the best offensive
lineman in football
and they got to start allocating some
resources on the demons inside of the
ball
you know we talked about it i think was
it last week or two weeks ago when we
hit the afc west
i mean it's crapola on the front seven
you know what i mean i don't mean
crapola but there's nobody special
there's nobody any team's game planning
going oh no
if we don't double team this guy we're
ruined you know oh gosh this pass rusher
whoa if we don't stop him and have a
back chip and send a tie down we'll
never beat them
they got nothing like that they have
nothing
i do think gus bradley and the defensive
side will help develop some of this
young
talent trayvon mullen abrams do things
like that
gus bradley is a really damn good coach
but yes
it hasn't been great so far i i can't
deny that
and i will say this too mike just before
the trent brown
hey he deserves some of this too you
know this is trent brown
two out of three teams that basically
get rid of them and why'd you pay him
why
i don't know you're right i'm not trying
to defend that was look
i think at the time we we sounded the
alarm he flamed out in san francisco
flamed out
they found a way to turn his performance
into chicken salad in new england that's
what new hampshire
is right and then in comes the raiders
and they think they can just plug this
guy
in and he's just gonna be as great as he
was in new england oh we're gonna make
him right tackle instead of life tackle
so what
we're gonna give him all this money and
yeah
another example of one of these guys who
gets signed the first day of free agency
and it's a big deal and it's a record
contract and
and it falls apart well and you're right
and but i'll say this in their defense
the new england wanted trent brown too
you know they just couldn't pay him the
amount of money the raiders i don't
think they weren't willing to do that
but yeah as of right now you know and
again
that was a risky sign because you're
right there was a lot of warnings
kyle shanahan loves offensive linemen he
i
i don't know what went on there but he
just doesn't let like the best right
tackles and football out the door
and not really get much in return for it
you know yeah new england got him
straight well we've seen new england do
that they can get guys straight that
others can't
because of the culture and everything
that's up there but yeah trent brown
went there and it
it's not because of play it's mayhawk
said it you know
when he plays he's one of the best in
the game it's all the other stuff
it's not you know being dedicated to
your craft that's what you hear about
trent brown so
uh there is no value and yeah it's it's
a mistake on the raiders and they get
they got some building to do to help
their football team
and i've had people ask me why isn't
mayok the one who's on the firing line
here because gruden runs the show
period and there was some chatter that
mayok was in trouble but
i believe based on what i've heard that
gruden realized he wasn't going to find
anybody better
see because when you're the coach and
you're also in charge it's much harder
for you
to pluck guys who are with other teams
to be your gm because you're really not
making them
the general manager of the team because
you retain all of the control
over the draft of the roster over
everything important so you have to go
outside the normal boundaries one of the
reasons why your guy kyle had to go get
john lynch sure because kyle retains so
much of the authority
you can't hire somebody from another
team one of the reasons why raiders
had to go get mike mayok he wasn't
attached to anyone you didn't have to
get
permission right that would have been
denied because gruden's in charge
gruden does a good job
of concealing to a certain extent the
fact that this is all on him
and it is i chris it is all on him and
and when you don't have that healthy
fear that if you screw up enough times
you're going to get fired you're more
willing to take risks
and they've taken a lot of risks and i i
credit them for acknowledging their
mistakes
instead of concealing them but again
when you're golden when you've got 10
years of job security
you don't need to worry about covering
up your mistakes no i i hear you
i i hear you you know and again they
made these moves
thinking they were gonna work yeah they
were wrong like i said the ones that
they took risk on
they're gonna backfire on them because
those are ones that just pop out and
you're gonna go what the hell were you
thinking with these picks or that
signing or whatever else
but there's still been a lot of
positives there there's no doubt
they were a better football team this
year you know they
they're close so i'm not gonna like
and again i understand everything you're
saying yeah he's he's got some wiggle
room
but he's again i know the guy he's he's
a psycho he's trying to do it the right
way yeah he made mistakes and now we're
holding him accountable right now
um but this is a huge off-season well
done
as long as mark davis doesn't he's fine
well but
but we see enough also on social media
that this
it's a real conversation about the
raiders you know once
you know people just continue to beat it
down and what the hell are you doing in
free agency in the draft and do that
you know mark davis will have no choice
but to listen here at some point
this is a crucial year for the raiders
it really is it's a big year for john
gruden mike mayok and that football team
there's a lot of things i like but
there's a lot of things i don't like and
they need to get to work on
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports